I was involved with this way before
there were extreme pogo sticks I like
most people at some point in their life
got a pogo stick for Christmas or
something like that one of the little
toy ones and I bounced on it for about
five minutes and I was like well this is
fairly important so for some odd reason
I decided to try to start doing tricks
on it and one thing led to another and
eventually there was a whole group of us
back worm from doing these tricks now
the pogo sticks you can clear about
eight to nine feet so you're in the air
for a long time and you have handlebars
and pegs and a whole body and so it's
just basically a forum for creativity
for the extreme pogo athletes carnegie
mellon university is the only University
in the entire world where pogo extreme
pogo technology is being developed well
the conventional pogo stick technology
is the coil spring made out of steel
which has some drawbacks particularly
it's heavy as the spring itself is quite
heavy are bogo uses a fiberglass spring
which flexes started in the leg lab here
in here the 80s with Mark Roberts
building various running dynamic running
machines the bow leg was a temp to build
a very efficient bouncing leg and that
was probably in 96-97 so that was sort
of the beginning of the
the whole bowleg concept which
eventually migrated into the bogo but
one of the things we wanted to do was to
show that we could scale up from a small
three or four pound robot up to a big
robot like a couple hundred pound robot
so we decided to put a human operator on
it when it flexes there's really you
know it there's nothing for it to rub
against really it's just pivot it at the
two ends so it's very low friction in
that sense and we also put in place of
the usual sliding plastic joints that
are used in pogo sticks we replace
everything with rollers which increases
the friction quite a bit it's the
smoothest ride of any pogo stick that
exists and it's sort of a mass consensus
among the whole polo community that
that's true and they get it's it is
favored to win the high jump at around
nine nine and a half feet the bogo is
patented by carnegie mellon and we have
a license agreement with an outside
company we're hoping that pogo palooza
will be sort of the coming out for the
logo the introduction of the bow go into
the you know the public there's a whole
host of reasons what people should come
to polka Palooza six first among them is
the fact that it will be unlike anything
they've ever seen ever there's literally
Pogo athletes from around the world who
are jumping over eight feet in the air
over cars doing massive backflips it's
it's unbelievable there's a three-day
tour where we're stopping all over the
place around the city doing shows
there's actually going to be a small
exhibit at the Carnegie Science Center
on extreme pogo and then there's a huge
competition in schenley plaza on the
final day which is August twenty second
you